I know what you're thinking you were
expecting to see here Simon Whistler and
obviously I'm not Simon Whistler and
Fonseca the Spanish version of Simon
Whistler I'm one of the co-hosts of
visual politic in Spanish and today I'm
at the Munich Security Conference
because we are gonna make an interview
to someone really really really special
nothing more and nothing less that Jens
Stoltenberg
Secretary General of NATO for those who
don't know it NATO is the military
alliance that comprises European nations
America and other countries like
Australia or Canada also mr. Stoltenberg
used to be the Prime Minister of Norway
and the leader of the Norwegians
Labour's party yes he's a social
democrat but he's more on the moderate
wing of the party during his
administration Norway modernizes its
army and for example is the moment where
they enter the f-35 program and now you
might wonder why are we so interested in
making an interview with the Secretary
General of NATO well the reality is that
neither nowadays is not having a really
good moment it feels like most of the
member countries wanted to disappear
last year Turkey sign an agreement with
Russia to buy weaponry from them and
that's surprising given that Russia used
to be the antagonist of NATO but that's
not the only problem macron Emmanuel
macron the French president said a few
months ago that NATO is brain dead and
that he wants to create a European army
you've seen it a thousand times here at
visual politic because we made a
thousand videos talking about the
European army they would be European
army how much is that challenging the
foundations of NATO but this is not the
only problem because Donald Trump three
years ago he said that the NATO was
pointless nowadays and even though it
seems that he kind of changed his mind
now it seems that he's going for
bilateral treaties between two nations
like America and Poland for example and
that that could be kind of a reward for
Poland because he likes Poland more than
Germany so he would be like retiring
troops from Germany and putting them on
Poland is he gonna do that and in case
he does it how does it's gonna challenge
neither what's the point of neither
today we don't have a cold war with
Russia anymore well today we're gonna
answer to all of these questions but
before we do no this time we're not
gonna take a look back at the history
we're gonna speak to jens stoltenberg
see you now
[Music]
well first of all mr. Stoltenberg
thank you so very much for coming here
and give us your time to answer some
questions i would like to start who
inspire you the most when you started
your political career what was the
figure that give you the inspiration you
know it's hard to the point that one
specific figure but I think that the the
society I saw in Norway and the Nordic
mobile where where we try to do things
together where we are trying to have a
high level of equal distribution of
wealth and at the same time give people
the chance to to get education and to
and to develop their own lives
that model of society inspired me and I
and I wanted to be part of that and if I
join the Baltics mm-hmm well they that's
interesting that so you don't have like
any specific a figure it was just a
model yeah as I think if anything I
think I think my mother was very
important for me and also my father day
they were they were very political
engaged in different yeah sure my mother
worked very much on women's rights that
time this was in the 70s and the issue
[Music]
also right to to leave and you go to
children kindergartens and so on and and
she also worked very hard on development
aid
I'm sure daughter who worked on issues
related to their Stoltenberg family it's
kind of a name in her way so well
talking about models this conference the
topic of this conference is West
lessness is how the West the model the
Western model is kind of losing its grip
so I would like to ask you what's the
role of a Western military alliance in a
West 'less world well the the role or
the task of NATO is to preserve peace so
that there is my night to exist is to
prevent war
we were we were established together
with the European Union after Second
World War to make sure that nothing that
happened again and and the NATO's task
is not to fight the war but the
preventive all our task is not to
provoke a conflict but to deter fear the
terror they are terrorists and the whole
idea is that as long as we as we sent a
clear message in the potential adversary
that they've won nato ally is attacked
the whole alliance will come and respond
and undefended ally then no one attack
us and that's the best way to prevent
the world actually that's a point where
i would like to do to take you because
okay i'm gonna go straight is from
dividing neither present chump has a
different style than some of the
political leaders but you know how to
remember that NATO is the lines of 29
different nations with in different
history different geography from both
sides of the Atlantic with different
political parties in government and of
course there are differences we are
different talking about for example when
America now started this bilateral
agreement with Poland and at the same
time don't Trump was kind of threatening
of Germany with retiring the troops from
Germany Avenue but it sounds doesn't
sound a little bit like punishment to
the country that didn't meet the
budgetary requirements and our reward to
those who do but the reality is that the
United States is increasing their
presence in Europe also in Germany and
and just as we speak we have a big
exercise called Europe defend the Europe
20 and then in this exercise the united
states deploys from the united states
also bringing over the atlantic 20,000
US troops that's the biggest number in
decades so so the reality on the ground
is that actually Europe and North
America are doing more together the
United States is increasing their
presence in Europe with more exercises
with with more infrastructure with more
pre-positioned equipment and European
allies are stepping up so yes there are
differences on climate change and trade
and Iran nuclear deal and many other
issues but when it comes to a core task
we have proven that despite
disagreements and differences we are
able to deliver on that protect and
defend it actually actually yeah you say
that the differences don't matter when
it comes to military or defense but okay
another example we have Turkey and
Greece they are both NATO members they
don't really have good relationships
with within each other and the tension
is increasing especially in the
Mediterranean the rhetorical tensions
doesn't that affect the stability of
NATO when two members are so first of
all both Turkey and Greece are highly
valued NATO allies and I contribute to
NATO in many different ways
with maritime capabilities help us in
the greater be happy are so both of them
are important
the second they they sit around the same
table in NATO everyday and we make
decisions on stepping up the fight
against terrorism or improving our cyber
defenses or declaring space as a new
operational domain so Turkey and and
Greece delivery together in NATO every
day then there are also some differences
between Turkey and Greece and of course
I'm not saying that these differences
are so easy to solve but I'm saying that
these differences have not made it
impossible for NATO to deliver and for
Greece and Turkey to work together in
NATO and the latest example is how we
address the migratory refugee crisis we
have the NATO presence in the Aegean Sea
where our Turkish ships Greek ships NATO
ships us all from all the NATO countries
working together to make sure that we
implement and follow up the agreement
between Turkey and the European Union on
the migrant crisis sure I mean that's a
good example of cooperation but how
about the weaponry
when Turkey just I think it was this
year on the sign an agreement to Dubai
s400 from Russia I mean Russia is like
the classical antagonist of NATO I'm not
saying we are confronting them all the
time but they are like our antagonist
they are buying weaponry from them well
first of all that's a national decision
is not for NATO to decide exactly what
kind of equipment different allies buy
but but I have expressed my own concerns
about the consequences of the Turkish
decision and and of course these new
s400 air defense systems which are
Russian will not be integrated into
NATO's integrated air and missile
defense there will be a standalone thing
outside NATO's air defense system so
they'll be there will be only part of
Turkey's army but they will never be
used for our multi lateral operations
but we have something called integrated
NATO air and missile defense where we
have you know diff
batteries we have we have radars we have
planes and all of these operate together
they share information they share and
situation awareness is shared the same
radar picture so we can use land-based
air defense batteries we can use planes
we can use drones we can use satellites
and all of this working together in
protecting net NATO airspace this is
very advanced way technologically
advanced systems integrating a lot of
information and protecting NATO airspace
and then of course we have different
systems in different nations totally
integrated so what I'm saying is that
the the Russian s400 which run and be
deployed in which to Turkey has acquired
will not be part of that will not be
integrated into the integrated right
interrupt you for a moment but I'm just
curious is it the first time that you do
something like this where you just
openly reject some weaponry from some of
the members you say okay you can have
this but we're not gonna use this is it
the first thing that happens or not I
don't know III guess that has happened
before but but the thing is that Turkey
will be still be part of NATO's into the
air and missile server all the
capabilities they are radars they have
they have planes they have all the
capabilities that are an actually NATO
has deployed Patriot batteries in Turkey
so Spanish Patriot batteries in Turkey
so so so so turkey is still part of it
of course but this specific system will
not be part of it okay but but let me
also add Turk has not asked for it
either so so the the Turk has not asked
for integrating and it will not do it
sure sure sure
let me just change my mom in the topic
another question I wanted to ask you is
how can you push or mm force member
countries to meet their budgetary
requirements it's 2 percent you can
remember for those who don't know it a
member countries of NATO they have to
spend 2 percent of their GDP military
how well what we do is that we remind
them of the commitment they all made
this was 29 allies actually that I'm
trying to strengthen eight allies
deciding in in Wales in unity Kingdom in
2014 that we had to invest more in
defence also I have been a politician
for many years and I understand that
most politicians they would like to
spend money on health care of
infrastructure on education instead of
defense and after the end of the Cold
War after the dissolution of the Warsaw
Pact
yeah but like I'm talking about is there
any specific measure well the most
important message we have is to is to
tell them that this is an obligation
they have made to all other NATO allies
and the realities that NATO allies are
now stepping up they are delivering on
the promise they have made because
because of the years of cutting defense
spending
now all allies are increasing defense
spending and more allies meet the target
of spending 3 percent of GDP on defense
and the majority of allies have plans in
place to meet that target sorry I would
like to now change to leave a topic of
conversation because we're gonna run out
of time look I'm not youtuber and I see
every day how there is like a
generational clash between the younger
generations who trust more social media
or platforms like YouTube more than
traditional TV and the more say senior
generation that likes they they don't
trust social media they definitely trust
more relying more on legacy media
because they think youtubers we lack the
accuracy that the traditional newspapers
or TV has so I would like to open a
little bit of a discussion here in this
in this conference and I would like is
there something that you would like to
know about a youtuber or a online media
a new media so first of all I believe
that we need
we need both I mean III don't think many
people they use both YouTube and they
use social media and they use some other
old media and and that's fine I for me
the most important is that we have free
press that we have journalists that can
ask the difficult questions and that and
and and that we have factual and
reliable sources of information whether
that comes in a YouTube video or in the
social media or Facebook or Twitter or
whether it comes in all the paper
newspaper to be honest that doesn't
matter so much for me and you are right
a different generations they are
attached to different kinds of media and
that I think that's very part of a
change development and I welcome change
on the augment well thank you anyway for
answering these questions to the new
media because I think that's that's very
mmm should be a good model for other
politicians perhaps well to wrap up this
conversation I would like to get a
little bit more portion and more
personal I have a question that some of
the people in our audience they they
were asking us if there is it's very
personal but I would like to I take some
time to answer if you want if there is a
war now and he's threatened you and your
family what would you do
so first of all the fact that we are
talking about that just reminds us of
how horrible and and bad war is I have
not ever lived in a country that has
suffered under war but my parents and
also my grandparents they lived in
Norway during the the Second World War
and and my grandfather was a priest no
war he fought in Norway during the war
and and they have told me so much about
you know the horrors the the fair they
they
they felt the so of course I will be
concerned about my own family
and how to protect them and for me this
just makes it even more important to do
my daily work because my daily work has
hit redundant NATO is to prevent that
from happening war is horrible
war is horrendous and that's exactly why
we need to prevent it and that's the
reason why we have institutions like
NATO when we have a more uncertain world
as we have now this is even more
important to have strong international
institutions ok another question that I
have from from the audience's please
complete the following sentence in a
peaceful world weapons are not used well
very good very sharp well I mean just
one world one word how would you like to
be remembered as a person that stood up
for peace and helped together with many
many other people to prevent war from
every gain happening in Europe and in
our part of the way in one in one word
how would you like to be remember in one
word as a peaceful man good well that's
a hell of a statement thank you so very
much mr. Stoltenberg it's been a
pleasure to have you here and well for
those who are watching the interview if
you wanna let us know what you think in
the comment section below you can do it
if you like this video give us a thumbs
up and of course subscribe to the you
rmse channel where you will have much
more content that we'll be publishing
during the following days thank you very
much and thanks for watching
[Music]